SUMI AGGARWAL: Welcome,
everybody, to Talks at Google.
It's my great
pleasure to introduce
Lesley Stahl, one of our
country's most preeminent
journalists.
She's been a correspondent
at "60 Minutes" for 25 years,
and has covered
pretty much everything
that's happened in the world
in the last quarter century,
from Guantanamo,
to all the wars,
to various
presidential campaigns,
to technology stories, which is
a particular area of interest
of hers, to sports.
She is the winner
of 11 Emmy awards.
And prior to
joining "60 Minutes"
was a White House correspondent
during the Carter and Reagan
administrations, and was a
moderator of "Face the Nation."
She is the author of
two books, including
the one that is on sale in the
back called "Becoming Grandma."
So highly encourage everybody
to pick up a signed copy
of the book on your way out.
Great Mother's day gift.
So get your shopping done early.
There's also cards back there.
So feel free to get
it done in one stop.
And she is the proud
grandmother of two girls.
Welcome, Lesley.
LESLEY STAHL: Thank you, Sumi.
Sumi neglected to say
that we're colleagues,
because Sumi worked at "60
Minutes" till less than a
year ago.
SUMI AGGARWAL: Yes.
I was a producer
there for many years.
LESLEY STAHL: We
worked together.
SUMI AGGARWAL: And had the
pleasure of working with Lesley
on a couple of stories.
It was great.
So tell me about the book.
Did becoming a
grandmother surprise you?
LESLEY STAHL: Well, I knew I
was going to be a grandmother,
so that didn't surprise me.
What surprised me
was the enormity
of that initial emotion.
This kind of wallop
of love that's
unlike any other kind
of loving that you
have for any other
creature on the planet.
It's nothing like mother love.
It's its own little animal.
And when you become
a grandmother,
you change so dramatically
that your children
don't recognize you.
They run around
saying, who is she?
Because you are so mush-bally.
You are just a puddle of
whatever the kid wants.
I believe that we are
actually-- that the word "no" is
incapacitated.
We cannot deny them anything.
But really, it was that initial
jolt of elation and emotion
that I wanted to explore.
What is that?
Do all grandmothers have that?
The answer is most of them do.
Do grandfathers have it?
They do, but it's different.
And look into the history, the
biochemistry, the anthropology,
the different kinds
of grandmothers--
step-grandmothers,
surrogate grandmothers.
And even when there's
tension in the family
with the daughter-in-law.
And there's a lot of tension
I wrote it as much
for your generation
as for my generation,
for young parents,
because we're in this together.
Young parents and their parents.
We're the family.
And so it's as geared
for my daughter,
who is a young woman with two
kids, as it is for my friends.
SUMI AGGARWAL: So
as I was reading
the book, the thing that was
most enlightening to me--
so I'm the mother of a young
daughter who's six years old.
But it really gave
me a look into what
my mom must be experiencing.
And how she comes to it.
And things that I feel like
can be a little meddlesome,
where I'm like, mom, I'm
not going to do that.
What are you talking
about And so it was really
an interesting kind
of insight into that.
LESLEY STAHL: Does she meddle?
SUMI AGGARWAL: Sorry?
LESLEY STAHL: Does
your mother meddle?
SUMI AGGARWAL: She
very carefully meddles.
She's very cautious about it.
What do you think
of modern parenting?
LESLEY STAHL: Well,
I'll tell you what
I think of modern parenting.
But first let me say
that most grandmothers I
met and interviewed, including
me, we walk on eggshells.
We are so careful.
We don't want our kids
to be angry at us,
because then we fear
they might deny us
access to the only thing
that really matters anymore.
And it's those babies.
So I had any number of
grandmothers I interviewed--
and I interviewed
a lot-- tell me,
my tongue hurts from biting it.
Or, I won't even lift
an eyebrow in criticism
of how they're doing it.
And then the minute
you leave the house,
you turn to your husband, or
he turns to you and you say,
we didn't do it that way
and she turned out OK.
We were good at it.
Well, the truth is we
weren't as good at it
as your generation is.
That's the truth.
SUMI AGGARWAL: But I think that
puts more pressure on parents
as well.
Now you're so concerned
about, they can't eat this.
They have to go to
bed at a certain time.
You have to follow the routine.
It's a lot more.
I mean, how did you manage that?
You had such a demanding career.
How did you manage it when
your daughter was younger?
LESLEY STAHL: Well, I think
my generation of women
was much more focused on just
getting into the workplace.
And it took a lot of energy
and a lot of attention.
We missed a lot with our
children that we regret.
I think our attention
was truly divided.
And I think our children--
you, my daughter,
a lot of the people
who work at Google
by the age I'm looking out
at here, you learned from us.
Or maybe you resent
what we did it,
but you're doing it differently.
And the truth is, I admire
the way you're doing it.
I admire the way my daughter
is putting a lot of emphasis
on her family.
Although, she has a big job.
But she still is more--
she's building a better nest
than I did.
I admit that.
SUMI AGGARWAL: And
what are the things
that you notice that you
have to bite your tongue for?
Not necessarily about your
daughter, but generally.
LESLEY STAHL: Oh,
I'll tell you one.
Sleep training.
I don't know how many
people here have children.
Have you--
SUMI AGGARWAL: Well, tell
us what sleep training is.
LESLEY STAHL: No, I know.
But at Google in general.
But I didn't sleep train,
so I had never heard of it.
Apparently, it's
been around for ages.
So the idea is after
a couple of months,
you just let the
baby scream and yell.
And I just happened
to be there when
it happened with my husband.
And I couldn't stand it.
They didn't pick her up.
They just let her scream
her little head off.
My skin was crawling.
But I didn't say a single word.
I just sat on it.
I was hyperventilating.
I thought I was
having a heart attack,
but I didn't say a word.
We get in the car, because
we were staying at a hotel.
My husband turns to me and
says, what was that all about?
And I said, what?
I didn't say a word.
I was the Sphinx.
He said, you didn't say a word?
You didn't shut
up the whole time.
So out of my mouth was,
why are you punishing her?
Why are you making
her-- I swear,
I didn't think I said a word.
And it was just tumbling out.
I didn't hear myself.
Weird.
I know.
But for the most part,
my generation of parents
is sitting on it or
trying to sit on it.
Because we want you to think
that we think you're wonderful,
so that you let us
have the babies.
SUMI AGGARWAL: And so
tell me a little bit
about some of the science that
you found out about as you
were researching this book.
What is the science
behind grandparenting?
What is the thing
that's happening?
LESLEY STAHL: Well, there's
two interesting things
above all the others.
One is the biochemistry.
That enormous
wallop that I felt.
And I felt it all over
my body, is actually
a biochemical response.
When a mother has a baby, her
brain is completely rewired.
And all kinds of different,
new hormones come into play.
A grandmother has
something somewhat similar.
Her brain is also rewired,
not as extensively
and not as dramatically.
But she also secretes
a bonding hormone.
And so she is physically binding
herself to that little baby,
just the way parents do.
Well, it's not the way parents
do because it's not as intense.
But we also go
through a connection
that holds us to that baby.
So that when we don't see
the baby, we crave the baby.
And it can happen to
a step-grandmother.
It can happen to a
surrogate grandmother.
It can happen to an
aunt, a great aunt.
But when that baby is a
little kid and somebody who
thinks of it as
somewhat theirs, holds
it-- there's all kinds
of physical changes
that go on within you.
So that's one thing I thought
was pretty interesting.
Oh, here's another thing.
The circuitry of baby
loving in the brain
and in the body, the wires,
are exactly the same wires
as romantic love.
They're the same pathway.
So what was happening
to me and all us
other grandmothers is
we're falling in love.
We are literally,
actually, falling in love.
And it feels like that.
And we use language like that.
People say, I fell off a cliff
when I held my grandchild.
Or, you feel just
wonderful all over.
Or, I crave them when
they're not there.
So it is exactly the
same animal of feelings.
And the other thing
I found out was
that most animals on
the planet die when
they can no longer reproduce.
So when a female stops
being able to have
babies, if she can walk or fly,
whatever, she goes over there
and dies.
Except for elephants,
whales, and humans.
So why do we have extended
lives beyond menopause?
Why do we even have menopause?
Well, the answer is to
take care of the babies.
Grandmother's raise the babies.
Both parents hunted.
They went out into the
fields and raised crops.
And they left the babies
home with grandma.
And so I think there is
in us a kind of atavistic,
granular need to help
raise the babies.
When we don't, we hurt.
SUMI AGGARWAL: It's almost
like we're coming full circle.
You talk about granny nannies.
What are granny nannies?
Tell us.
LESLEY STAHL: Granny
nannies are grandmothers
who take care of
the babies two days
a week, three or four days
a week to help their kids.
And today, in this country
now post-recession,
both parents are working.
And they're not making
as much as one person
made in my generation.
So you need the help because
child care, good child care,
is exorbitantly expensive.
I'm not telling anybody
anything they don't know.
It can cost as much as college.
So the babysitting
function is needed.
And my generation is spending--
here's a statistic I came upon.
My generation is spending seven
times more on grandchildren
than grandparents
did 10 years ago.
And I'm not talking about toys.
I'm talking about the crib.
I'm talking about the car seat.
I mean, major items.
We're sending the
kids to school.
We're paying medical.
We're straightening their teeth.
Grandparents are really
contributing in many ways.
SUMI AGGARWAL: Where does
grandpa fit into all of this?
LESLEY STAHL: Oh, grandpa.
If grandmas think that we go
through a sea change, which
we do.
Our personalities change when
we're with those children.
I mean, with our kids,
we were policeman.
And with our grandchildren,
we're playmates.
Whatever they want.
Grandfathers also go through
this huge metamorphosis.
For a grandfather who
worked very hard when
the little ones-- his own
little ones were growing up,
they all think about
it as a second chance
to watch a child grow
up, to be in their lives.
And a lot of
grandmothers told me,
grandpa's a better
babysitter than I am.
He's more patient.
He's more playful.
I saw this over and over.
Grandfathers are the
nannies, not grandmothers.
In many marriages,
the husband is older.
He retires.
Grandma's still working.
So he's the one who's
taking care of the babies.
And he's doing a great job.
And he loves it.
And if he has health
problems, the children
are alleviating them.
They're getting
rid of depression.
They're staving off dementia.
I mean, these are
actually studies
that show that babies just
have this effect on us.
It makes us healthier.
It makes us happier.
It makes us younger.
I know.
SUMI AGGARWAL: To
segue a little bit,
it is election season after all.
And all the presidential
candidates are grandparents.
So I have to ask you, what do
you make of the race so far?
LESLEY STAHL: Well,
one, I actually
thought age was
going to be an issue.
When Hillary
Clinton announced, I
thought that the
Republicans were
going to come in with a whole
coterie of younger candidates.
And they were just going to
harp and bang away at her being
in her late 60's.
Uh-uh.
I mean, Bernie's 74.
She's only 68.
Do we know how old Trump is?
Is he 69?
Something like that.
SUMI AGGARWAL: I think 69, yeah.
LESLEY STAHL: I was very
interested in Hillary
being a grandmother because when
I started working on the book,
she announced that
she was pregnant.
I mean, her daughter
was pregnant.
Whoa.
SUMI AGGARWAL: It's not
the "National Enquirer."
LESLEY STAHL: That's a lead.
And so I was curious
as to whether her
being a grandmother--
well, whether she'd use it.
And whether it would help her
or not to win the presidency.
So I went with Frank Luntz,
who's a Republican pollster,
to New Hampshire to sit
in on a focus group.
And he tacked on a
couple questions for me,
and then let me
ask some questions.
So they were all Republicans.
And he got up there and he said,
what one word would you use
to describe Hillary Clinton?
Oh, god.
If Hillary Clinton
had been in the room,
she would crawl up in a
ball and go sit in a closet.
Dishonest, liar, cold.
They didn't say
corrupt, but that's
what Trump is picking up on.
But words like that.
All negative.
All having to do
with dishonesty.
It was brutal.
Then, he let me get up.
And I asked, what one word comes
to mind when I say grandmother?
Oh my gosh, the words
were just-- all of them.
Nobody had one even remotely
negative thing to say.
It was loving, cozy, cookies,
unconditional love, lap, warm.
So I asked them-- now,
they're all Republicans--
if they thought if
Hillary played up
that she's a grandmother,
some of those words
would rub off on her.
And I was surprised because
they were all self-described
as conservative Republicans.
Several of them,
many of them, said
they thought it would help
her as long as she didn't,
they said, exploit the child.
Meaning walk around
with the kid on her hip.
I'm sure Hillary's people have
done their own focus groups.
I'm a little surprised she
hasn't made more of it.
It could be that all the
other candidates are also
grandparents, I don't know.
But that focus group
led me to believe
that it would soften her image.
And she's still having
those words come up
in all focus groups,
including with Democrats.
So she could use a little--
SUMI AGGARWAL: Yeah.
LESLEY STAHL: People never
make much out of grandfathers.
Grandmothers, it's going
to be the word in front
of every woman who's ever
had a position of authority.
She's a grandma.
But grandfathers don't get that.
SUMI AGGARWAL: Right.
That's kind of a given.
LESLEY STAHL: I know.
SUMI AGGARWAL: What do you make
of Trump, the Trump phenomena?
LESLEY STAHL: Oh my goodness.
SUMI AGGARWAL: Got to ask.
LESLEY STAHL: I mean,
I'm like everybody else.
I don't know what to make of it.
It's not that I don't
know what to make of him.
I don't know what to make of
the public reaction to him.
I could go through
a litany of things
he has said where I was sure--
I would have put money down
that it was over.
When he went after
John McCain, saying he
wasn't a hero-- now that
was really early on.
I knew for sure
that was the end.
I knew it.
Well, there have been
13, 14, 15 of those.
And he always rises
from the ashes.
So I wouldn't dare predict
and it's even hard to analyze.
But I know, I've pretty
darn sure, pretty
darn sure it's going to
be Hillary versus Trump.
And they're really going
to do jobs on each other.
It's really going to be a slug
fest of gigantic proportion.
Who can slime the other one
more is probably going to win.
Isn't that awful to
say about our country?
The other thing that strikes
me about this campaign-- and I
think I've been struck
by it in the past,
but never so intensely-- is how
few people give the candidates
to us.
If you go out and count
all the people who
either went to a caucus
or voted in a primary,
it's a minute fraction of the
American adult population.
And so the process just
doesn't-- it's not working.
We have to fix it.
Just have to fix it.
SUMI AGGARWAL: And
the thing that strikes
me, as a former
journalist, is, how do you
report on somebody like Trump
when there's no fact checking?
I know at "60 Minutes,"
very particular.
Every script is footnoted.
Everything is fact checked.
How do cover a candidate
in a responsible way who
really can't be fact checked,
or doesn't care, or--
LESLEY STAHL: Well,
he is fact checked,
but the public doesn't care.
There are any number of
newspaper columns written
about what he got wrong.
Television stories done
And people don't care.
That's why I say it's the
reaction to him that's
the unfathomable part of it.
It's very difficult
to report on him.
I've studied his interviews.
Because you know, I used
to do "Face the Nation."
And I used to love to
try and pin someone down
if they didn't want to
answer the first question.
You went to the second question.
And then, if you go to
the third, you're nagging.
But I would nag.
He's unnagable.
You just can't get him
to answer the question.
He gets away from it.
So it's hard.
SUMI AGGARWAL: And where is
the line between entertainment
and journalism?
As you said, if this is going
to turn into a slug fest,
it almost feel like a little
bit of a horse race, a boxing
match, whatever you
want to call it.
LESLEY STAHL: How
about stand-up comedy?
No, seriously.
Have any of you just sat
and watched a Trump rally?
None of you?
He is hilarious.
He is seriously hilarious.
It is a stand-up routine.
And I always thought that humor
was really, really important
in politics.
Because I covered Reagan
and he was very funny.
But sweetly funny, but funny.
I also thought
likeability was crucial.
It's certainly crucial to
leadership, to governing.
But we are being presented by
this tiny sliver of the country
with candidates who are more
unlikable than candidates
I think have ever been.
Well, in time that we know of.
Certainly, in modern time.
The negatives, woo.
Trump's are-- he has an
unfavorable rating of 67%.
And Hillary?
Anybody want to guess?
56% negative.
SUMI AGGARWAL: And
so as you said,
you covered Reagan
for a long time.
What do you make of the
almost deification of Reagan?
LESLEY STAHL: Of Reagan?
SUMI AGGARWAL: Yeah.
LESLEY STAHL: Well,
he wasn't deified
in the beginning at all.
In fact, there's a
little bit of similarity.
There was a huge
chunk of the country--
because Reagan was very,
very, very conservative
for that period of time in our
history-- who thought never
Reagan.
So there was that huge chunk
of the population out there.
The election was very close.
Then he was shot early on.
And he handled that
with such grace
and, really, heroism that
he won everybody's heart.
And people stopped and
stopped looking at him
in a two-dimensional way as a
guy who stood for these issues
and started to see
the human being.
And he had a quality.
And it's a quality we're not
seeing this time in anybody.
He had sweetness.
He had a special
quality of sweetness.
And when you saw him, you
could disagree with him 100%
and like him.
And it goes a huge,
long way to govern when
you need to persuade people.
SUMI AGGARWAL: Is the era of
sweetness over do you think?
Is there no room left in our--
LESLEY STAHL: Oh, well,
I would never say that.
When Jimmy Carter
was president, there
was so much gloom and doom.
Reagan used to run around
the country saying, what's
with the gloom and doom?
But there was.
We were very pessimistic.
Nothing was working.
There were gas lines.
There were food
lines for people.
People were suffering so much,
they were standing in line
to get food.
We had high inflation,
high unemployment.
You never thought it was
going to turn around.
And Reagan came in.
And pretty soon, we
were feeling good again.
The economy cranked back up.
So I mean, these
things are cyclical.
I think we might
have sweetness again.
SUMI AGGARWAL: One can hope.
I want to bring you
back to something
you were saying earlier
about Hillary Clinton
being a grandmother.
And one of the
interesting things
to bring it back
your book as well,
was when you wrote about
how being a grandmother
actually helps women
break the glass ceiling.
Tell us a little bit about that.
LESLEY STAHL: OK.
First of all, you will observe
that women in high places
today are grandmothers.
Nancy Pelosi, when she was sworn
in as Speaker of the House--
is she?
Yeah.
Do you remember then?
You all remember she had
all her grandchildren
on the stage with her.
And I actually did
a story on her.
She "ruled" in a maternal way.
She ruled the house with an iron
fist, but a maternal iron fist,
like the mother,
the policewoman.
She had an instinct that said
that grandmother image can
be a formula for authority.
And so I came to
see that while it's
still difficult for the
country as a whole, and for men
specifically, to
accept a young woman
in a position of
authority, it's not
hard to accept a grandmother.
Because very often
in our families,
they were the tough
one in the family.
And so I had a
girlfriend tell me--
she ran a girls'
school in New York.
And for her, she
was there forever.
She stayed at that school
and ran that school
for years and years and years.
She always had trouble
with the fathers.
They were always in her
face telling her what to do
and poking at her.
One day, it just stopped.
It just stopped.
And she was able to control
the meeting with the father
and everything was wonderful.
And then she realized
that he was seeing her
not as a young, sexy woman,
but as a grandmother.
And so his need to fight with
her, or to challenge her,
stand up to her, was over.
So grandmothers can
be authoritative
in the public's eye.
And again, I'm surprised Hillary
isn't playing it up more.
And you know, grandmothers
aren't old anymore.
They're baby boomers.
And baby boomers are young.
They think of
themselves as young.
They act young.
They dress young.
They look young.
Believe me, we're tired.
I'm telling you that when I
chase after my grandchildren,
I am very tired.
But we put on a good face.
Another grandmother in
the audience laughing.
So I don't think we have the
same image that grandmothers
had certainly when
I was growing up.
Or maybe even when
you were growing up.
SUMI AGGARWAL: And so
here in the Valley,
we talk a lot about
diversity in tech and making
sure that there's representation
of women on teams, especially
in the more technical fields.
With a little bit of
distance and perspective,
what do you make of that?
Especially given your research.
LESLEY STAHL: Well,
I'll tell you,
this happened at "60 Minutes,"
too, while you were there.
I fear so often that women
take two steps forward
and a step and a half back.
We take three steps
forward and two steps back.
And it's been that way ever
since the women's movement
in the early '70s.
We think we're making
progress in the workplace
and then we find out that
we're still only making
$0.79 to the men's dollar.
We still don't crash
through the glass ceiling.
We still don't have many CEOs.
And it's a bafflement.
It's a bafflement that we don't
have more women in positions
of executive positions
where they're
making the big decisions.
When it's shown that women
make better decisions
in many situations.
And where women are better
educated, generally speaking.
As many PhDs and so forth.
So it's a bafflement.
And it's like a little
ache because I was there
at the beginning of the
women's rights movement
where I was so sure-- so
sure that women were just
going to sweep into
the presidency,
into the boardrooms,
into the executive suites
in huge numbers within 30 years.
And it's more than 40 years
ago that this started.
So I don't know.
I keep saying the
time will come,
but when's it going to come?
SUMI AGGARWAL: If there are
any questions in the audience,
please feel free.
But in the meantime--
AUDIENCE: I guess two things.
First of all, regarding women,
I think that there was a change.
Not enough, but
there is a change.
And maybe I'm an
optimist, but it
seems like it shifted from
the world doesn't let women
do anything to that as well.
But also, I think the
education back at home.
I think parents should change
as well, not just the world.
Not just the corporations.
I think that still many
homes, not even intentionally,
are not raising
the girls in a way
that they even understand there
are options other than being
a girl or whatever it means.
LESLEY STAHL: Really?
I'm surprised to
hear you say that.
AUDIENCE: I think we, as
parents, are-- at least some
of us, not doing the best job.
Not necessarily because
we don't want to,
but because we're
not aware of it.
Because we grew up, even
my generation, in a way
that women has [INAUDIBLE].
LESLEY STAHL: OK.
Where did you grow up?
AUDIENCE: In Israel, and then
in the United States later.
But in Israel.
And I think that it's still-- I
saw a lot of conservative-type
of homes.
And again, not because
they wanted [INAUDIBLE].
LESLEY STAHL: Here?
AUDIENCE: In Israel.
But also, I think I see it here.
That it's conservative in a
way that nobody said that you
cannot be an engineer,
but it's not the point.
I mean, we're not talking
about a girl as an engineer.
LESLEY STAHL: You're
talking about being
told-- having a girl being told
you can be whatever you want.
That should be the message.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
But I don't think that--
LESLEY STAHL: But it should be.
AUDIENCE: I don't think that's
very common, even today.
And not because the parents
are objecting to it.
But still, it's
very conservative
that girls are girls
and boys are boys.
And at least what
I'm trying to do,
because nobody has the
golden-- is girls can be girls,
boys can be girls.
But I'm trying to mix and match.
So at least she knows she
can do whatever she wants.
LESLEY STAHL: You know, that's--
AUDIENCE: And that's hard.
LESLEY STAHL: I come
from, obviously,
a different generation.
I was told I could
be anything I want.
And so I'm a little
surprised to hear
you say all these generations
later you don't think
that that message is still
being sent to our kids.
Because that would
be a message that
comes down from my generation.
AUDIENCE: Look at Google.
The numbers that were
released to the public
shows that even
Google, where we're
doing whatever we can to
get as many women as we can,
especially engineers.
There is not enough women
graduating universities
in computer science.
LESLEY STAHL: And you
think that's the parents?
Really?
I thought that
was peer pressure.
AUDIENCE: I think it's
partially the parents.
LESLEY STAHL: Girls think that
boys won't like them if they
go into science kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: I think
that it's indirect.
And again, I don't think
that a lot of the parents
are doing this in purpose.
I think that in many cases,
they don't even think about it.
And at least in my case,
I think about that.
I don't know if I'm
doing the right thing,
but I think about that.
And if anyone will convey any
other message to my daughter,
that's one of the things
that can really freak me out.
LESLEY STAHL: Good message.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LESLEY STAHL: For everybody
who's listening, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And if we can go back to
television for a second--
LESLEY STAHL: Anything.
AUDIENCE: So
television was always
my dream, especially in news.
LESLEY STAHL: You wanted
to be a newscaster?
AUDIENCE: Always.
LESLEY STAHL: Here or in Israel?
AUDIENCE: Here.
This is the mecca
of-- and sometimes,
I report to Israeli television,
but just as a side hobby.
But what I did
learn from reporting
to radio and television
in Israel for,
let's say, 30 times
in my life, that it's
just unbelievable what happens
when something is broadcasted.
No one is watching broadcast
television, double quote.
It's all video on demand.
It's all Hulu and Netflix.
Nobody's watching
anything on TV.
TV is dead and everything.
But when my piece was
broadcasted on television,
my cellphone was
drained out of battery
from so many Facebook messages.
So my question to you is,
when you go into a studio,
not even reporting
from the field,
today after so many
years, what do you
feel when you record in studio?
When you see a piece
that you did broadcasted,
what does it make you feel?
And what do you think the impact
today versus a few years ago?
LESLEY STAHL: I guess
the thing that I
feel is that I'm not sure
I'm having an impact.
And it bothers me.
I don't know how many stories
you did for "60 Minutes,"
but I've done a lot.
Hundreds and hundreds.
And many of them important,
important information
that the public should know.
Change should have been made.
And it just sort of evaporates.
I feel it evaporates.
So I guess people
have said to me,
oh, you have so much influence.
I fear that we don't.
And I fear because we're doing
serious work, that's what
"60 Minutes" is really about.
So if we uncover an
injustice, or if we
show some corruption and
then nothing happens,
it's very discouraging.
Sometimes, you have to have
the public exposed to a story
over and over.
It has to linger before
it really has an impact.
So "60 Minutes" does it, and
then someone else picks it up.
And then maybe a congressman
makes a speech about it.
Maybe someone tries
to pass a law.
It has to go on and on.
So you know, I sit
in the studio and I
say to myself, OK,
is anybody going
to do anything about this?
That's what I think.
SUMI AGGARWAL: But that
said, "60 Minutes" still
is the news magazine of record.
LESLEY STAHL: It is.
SUMI AGGARWAL: You get an
average of 15 million viewers
every weekend.
LESLEY STAHL: But what happens?
Did you ever do a story
that produced change?
SUMI AGGARWAL: I did.
LESLEY STAHL: You did?
SUMI AGGARWAL: I did one.
And I was very,
very proud of that.
LESLEY STAHL:
Which one was that?
SUMI AGGARWAL: The sugar one.
LESLEY STAHL: And it
really produced change?
SUMI AGGARWAL: It
produced some change.
It got the FDA to
start re-looking
at some of the classifications
that they had done.
But no, I know exactly what you
mean, where you do the story
and you're jazzed
for months going,
this is going to be amazing.
LESLEY STAHL: It's going
to blow the lid off.
SUMI AGGARWAL: And then you
send it out into the world and--
LESLEY STAHL: A
little crack, maybe.
SUMI AGGARWAL: So
that said, do you
think television
news is-- should we
be planning the funeral?
LESLEY STAHL:
Well, first of all,
television news has
changed dramatically.
It's interesting that
"60 Minutes" hasn't.
We're still doing
it the old way.
We still use the old stopwatch.
The way I [INAUDIBLE].
SUMI AGGARWAL: [INAUDIBLE]
digital on that stopwatch.
LESLEY STAHL: Well, but
it's still a stopwatch.
The stories are
done the same way.
Same ethics.
Same standards, all of it.
But most news is changed because
of the shrinking of the time
it takes between the
reporter learning
something and the reporter
getting it out there.
When I started,
there was a whole day
to think because
we worked in film.
And film had to be processed.
And so you could really
make a hundred phone calls.
And you could really suck
your thumb for an hour or two
and think it over.
And then when we got videotape,
that time was shorter.
And then we got cable.
And those reporters had to
be on the air pretty quickly.
And now there's no time.
And that has changed the
nature of news dramatically.
So whether it's on television or
on the web, the nature of news,
by definition, is
completely, totally altered.
If I were doing daily reporting,
say covering the White House,
I wouldn't begin to
know how to do it today.
I really needed to make
a lot of phone calls.
And I needed to understand it.
And I don't understand how
you can just run out there.
I don't do that at
"60 Minutes" still.
So I'm kind of one
of the lucky ones.
But I think that
news is morphing.
I'm not saying it's
better or worse, actually.
I shouldn't be judging, but
it's definitely different.
But I think the appetite
for news is enormous.
I think people want to know.
They want to devour.
And a lot of people
want in-depth reporting.
I mean, our audiences
are enormous.
And websites that are doing
in-depth investigative
reporting are surviving
and are healthy.
So I think people want
this kind of work,
but not a lot of [INAUDIBLE].
Not enough.
AUDIENCE: Keeping
on the news thing,
how do you feel about the
trend to so-called "comedy
news" like Stewart and Oliver?
LESLEY STAHL: Yeah.
What do I honestly think between
you and me and 38 other million
people?
I think they're brilliant.
It's satire.
And it's a form of commentary
that people listen to.
People want to laugh.
We started out saying
that Trump-- one
of the reasons I
think he's successful
is that he's really funny.
People want to laugh.
And if you feed them the
cereal with sugar on top,
they digest it.
I did the Bill Maher
show the other night.
He's brilliant.
He's hilarious.
Well, I used to watch
"The Daily Show."
I enjoy it.
It's part of our life now.
It's part of our
society and our life.
It was a little
discouraging to find out
that that was the only
news some of our children
were listening to.
That was a little hard to take.
But you know, as the
kids get a little older,
they start wanting something
a little more serious.
At least that's what
I'm seeing in my family.
So I'm all for it.
Are you against it?
AUDIENCE: No.
LESLEY STAHL: Oh, no.
You love it too?
AUDIENCE: I see Oliver
as the "60 Minutes" of--
LESLEY STAHL: Absolutely.
Oliver is brilliant.
But Bill Maher really
impressed me the other night.
I think they're great.
AUDIENCE: So talking about
the immediacy of news
versus the writing
of the book, how
did the process differ for you?
Were you employing a lot of
the same skills and techniques,
or was it a new
hat and experience?
LESLEY STAHL: It was new.
Well, the reporting wasn't
new, but the writing
was really hard.
Because the first draft that
I showed my husband, who's
a writer, he said, this is a
series of "60 Minutes" pieces.
So I could write
about 15 minutes.
But to write long form like
that really took a lot of work
for me.
I had to figure out how to
thread everything together,
which I could do it for 15
minutes and that was it.
But I've really loved
working on this book.
I met so many different kinds
of grandmothers and grandfathers
across the country.
And to find out that we're
all in this together,
we grandparents we're a society.
And our children and
how they relate to us.
Meaning your generation, how
you relate to us, is a society.
We're so connected.
We're all in this campaign so
aware of how different we are.
But we are all the
same grandparents.
Believe me, we're all the same.
We all love these
kids intensely.
We all change in the
way we grandparent.
None of us can wait to
see those grandchildren.
We annoy our children
because even if we're not
saying anything critical, we
are doing a little body language
thing that really
irritates them.
And we're trying not to.
So we are one big community.
And I found that out.
And it was very heartening.
But writing was a challenge.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned that you're
disappointed that
women haven't reached
higher levels in professions.
LESLEY STAHL: En masse.
AUDIENCE: En masse.
And one thing that
occurs to me is that when
grandparents are living
close by to their children,
and they're willing to help out
with the child care, that that
may allow their daughter
to be in her profession
longer and reach higher levels.
But it seems like
in this world, it's
a very international world.
And we have people moving
across continents to take jobs.
And their parents don't
always come with them.
LESLEY STAHL: But
a lot of them do.
AUDIENCE: And so I
guess my question is,
what is the responsibility
of women who have achieved
high levels in their profession
to make sure that they mentor
other women or create
policies in the workplace
to allow other women to
rise when they don't have
as many advantages,
support perhaps?
LESLEY STAHL: Well, women
should mentor women, period.
It's almost a given that
we need to help each other.
So that is a necessity.
We haven't solved the
problem of child care.
We just haven't.
It may be one of
the main reasons
that women don't
achieve because they
break their careers in half.
Because they feel
they have to be home
because they don't trust
the child care situation,
the daycare situation.
It's a conundrum.
I'm not a policy person.
I wish there were more
policy people working on it.
And more openness from
our elected officials
to try and create a structure,
a grid, some way for families
to be able to go to
work with peace of mind.
It's a terrible, unsolved crisis
in the country-- child care.
And I do come around
at the end of my book
to say that this is the perfect
way from grandparents to end
their extended retirement.
And maybe not all
grandparents move,
but there is a huge
trend going on right now
of grandparents moving to
be near their grandchildren.
They do it selfishly.
They want to be in
the babies lives.
The smart parents will overlook
the little critical elbowing
and say, we need you.
Because a woman going
to work will never
trust anybody as
much as she'll trust
her mother with her children.
So for a lot of women,
that is the answer.
For women whose parents
cannot come and be near them,
we need more
government to help us.
We do.
Or societies.
Or rotary clubs.
I mean, something.
So it's something I
thought a lot about when
I wrote the book.
I also wrote about
surrogate grandmothering,
parents who for any number
of reasons-- I mean,
parents my age cannot be
with their own grandchildren.
Maybe they don't have any.
Or maybe their daughters or
sons aren't going to have them.
Or maybe the daughter-in-law
is not going to have it.
But they can surrogate
grandparent another child
somewhere else.
It's a good way to take the
last 30 years of your life
because we're going
to live a long time.
And we'll be
healthy, most of us.
SUMI AGGARWAL: And with
that great thought,
I want to thank Lesley
for coming to Google.
LESLEY STAHL: Thank you.
SUMI AGGARWAL: We appreciate it.
My pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
SUMI AGGARWAL: And
I know you have
to dash because you have to get
up to San Francisco and battle
Bay Area traffic.
But we have books in the back.
So please, stop
by and grab some.
LESLEY STAHL: And this is the
best Mother's Day present you
can you give your mother.
I'm not kidding.
Grandmothers are
adoring this book
because I'm talking about them.
SUMI AGGARWAL: LESLEY
STAHL: Thank you, Leslie.
LESLEY STAHL: Thank you again.
Thank you, Sumi.